[Musik]
hellwig sag doch nicht wachsen wenn sie
hier reinkommt und die füchse
gerade für sieben oscars nominiert und
das ist möglich ist nicht nur dafür in
der woche sondern es ist eigentlich der
firma des jahres obwohl es ja noch so
jung es ist nämlich eine der besten
filme die in den letzten monaten mit
sicherheit ins kino gekommen
meine tochter angel wurde vor sieben
monaten ermordet die polizei scheint
mehr damit beschäftigt schwarze zu
foltern als echte verbrechen aufzuklären
freund mitbringt ist eine mutter ihre
vergewaltigte und getötet tochter
betrauert aber für die trauer tag einen
anderen ausdruck findet als ihrerseits
gewalt und aggression und dieses riebel
prozent titel werden also von frances
mcdormand gemietet und darin anzuklagen
dass ihre tochter nun schon fast immer
noch keine verhaftung gibt und wie kann
das sein
sheriff geologie ich würde alles tun um
den täter zu fassen
es ist aber wenn die dna von keinem mann
stand er hier verhaftet wurde
und wenn die dna zu keinem anderen täter
passt landesweit und wenn es keine
zeugen gibt von dem moment als sie ihr
haus verlassen hat bis zu dem zeitpunkt
als wir sie gefunden haben gibt es nicht
allzu viel was wir noch tun können
es geht in ihrem film eigentlich darum
wie gehen die einzelnen figuren mit
ihren gefühlen und welche antworten
finden sie auf die frage wie sie nicht
lösen können und dann unter umständen
doch mal einen moment von intimität
denen sie in der lage sind herzustellen
und das ist so das kommt so überraschend
und solo dürfen dann auch wieder obwohl
es letztlich so gar nichts führt außer
eben zu dem porträt komplexe
persönlichkeit in diesen förmiges ganz
wunderbaren du musst dich mir gegenüber
nicht rechtfertigen wolle mit einem
zwerg essen ist natürlich rechtfertige
mich doch überhaupt nicht ein bisschen
schon
frances mcdormand spielten alle fügen
sie eigentlich in den filmen der count
wales vor allem vergrößern
sehr langen einblicks sich vorbereitet
auf diese frau die vollständig alles in
die eigene hand nimmt die über sie
überhaupt nicht scheut molotow cocktails
und polizeistation zu werfen die sich
auch nicht scheut einen kleinwüchsigen
mann gespielt von peter den wird der
ihnen gefallen so gehe ja eigentlich
wirklich muss man sagen eine holzleiter
total zu beleidigen
seine frau ist das unangenehm teile sind
wahnsinnig schlagfertig
hallo ja die dose geworfen welche dose
was ist mit dir schätzchen weißt du wer
sie geworfen hatte
der film hat auch eine nominierung
bekommen für das beste originaldrehbuch
das jetzt insofern ganz berechtigt uns
nur weil diese geschichte einerseits so
spezifisch ist habe es gibt auch drei
reden sozusagen in diesem film und die
sind so toll geschrieben dass man
entweder war wirklich ein großer meister
an werke aus dem spricht unglaublich
viel gefühl für ja eigentlich ganz was
man den figuren so in dieser geschichte
eigentlich zutraut dass das ganz ganz
ganz schönen dann waren sie ist also
nicht den kleines loch beim dicken
fetten jeffrey in den dicken fetten
daumennagel geburt hat nein
es seien fünf erwachsenen würdig sein
für menschen die ins kino gehen weil sie
sich eine erweiterung ihrer vorstellung
von möglichkeiten zwischen menschen
erhoffen
obwohl das spektrum letztlich der
handlungen relativ gering ist weil es
eben immer wieder auf gewaltrausch lag
bis zum ende zeigt er eine eine große
komplexität einen gefühls möglichkeiten
sind schön
und für traurig dieses spektakel um
diese billboards auch ist
[Musik]
diese reporterin hofft dass das endlich
das ende bedeutet für diese sonderbare
geschichte der drei bilder und freiheit
der katastrophe
das ist erster verkappter anfangen
sender das mal in deiner guten morgen
mit sony frühstücksfernsehen scheitere
misst stimmen
[Musik]